thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another very
powerful episode of the careful boys we
have Steve joining us again no big deal
no big deal I just say that as a
formality I don't actually care we do it
who whoever's in this chair we just do
that because because you're you're
trying to buy time yeah but more
importantly we know the game more
importantly Bart has returned after a
short Hiatus what's up Bart
hello
he doesn't know how to do it yeah I
don't know how to do it I wasn't caught
up uh you know since uh last time last
time we were chatting with Bart things
were like all gravy and funny and cool
and you know it was all exciting and the
next time I'm jumping in different
because you're just dancing around a
weird subject man
the dancer Can't Stop Moving just say it
you don't have to cut the hole at the
bottom of the popcorn exactly the chick
to jack you off okay you can just say
can you jack me off we want to Jack you
out for anything
just whip it out just whip it out just
whip it out get to the point I just
don't think 911 happened
there it is
since your dad's funeral home all right
yeah he actually hasn't had a funeral
but uh since his passing since his
passing yes this is passing yeah it's
been nuts why are you laughing Nick this
is a [ __ ] serious topic I'm not
laughing at that I'm laughing at you
dude
you made me laugh wait what are you
talking about dude we're talking about
serious stuff that week that you were
filming JK news and when I was in here
did they even know that you got the news
of what happened and then you just did a
whole three days of JK news yeah yeah
um I don't think the the fans know but
pretty much what happened was I was
planning on making a trip back to LA
because we were going to shoot three
days of JK news
um I think it was going to be was like
Sunday Monday Monday Tuesday it was like
one of those weird days because that was
the only time that uh everyone's
schedules fit
and um I was gonna come in like pretty
much Sunday morning
and I already had booked my flight and
everything and then on Saturday which is
literally the day before
um I get a text from my mom and then she
texts me and she was like hey your dad
just killed himself and then I was like
what the [ __ ] like what does that mean
like are you like is that Google
translate gone wrong or is it an
exaggeration like did he eat something
spicy like sometimes like like it like
in you know like
it's like uh what's the word
self-preservation yeah like you say
something crazy like oh right like your
dad went crazy it doesn't mean it was
like cuckoo like literally yeah bought
the watch you shouldn't have bought or
something right like some some [ __ ] like
dude I gotta talk about nachos he just
killed himself
exactly what the [ __ ] am I but that's so
weird it's like call my mom and then my
mom's like
um yeah all the cops are here your dad
passed away uh take care of a bunch of
stuff and I was like what the [ __ ] I was
like that's [ __ ] crazy we hang up I'm
literally like in the bed like my hand's
kind of shaking because like it's just
the craziest news I've ever heard I've
never expect anything like that and then
I'm like staring at the wall I'm like
did that just happen or did I have a
dream like
what's going on
I go see Geo and I'm like hey um I just
I just laid it out hey are you busy no
like I don't even know how to like I
don't know how to massage the
information I was just like I my dad
killed himself that's it and she's like
you need to go to your mom right now and
then so pack my [ __ ] drove straight to
La how did you stay awake what do you
mean it was like midday Oh I thought you
were in bed sleeping no no like it was
like like three like 2 p.m 3 P.M it's
like 3 P.M dude how did you stay awake
8 P.M be very hard but um yeah so as I
was driving I was like you know when
your adrenaline kind of chills a little
bit and I'm starting to think I'm like
none of this [ __ ] makes sense I'm like
is this one of those [ __ ] Antics that
my mom's pulling because my mom like
ever since I've grown up she has like
the craziest Antics where I was like
maybe this is one of those things where
she's like oh I wonder if my son would
come to me at the drop of a dime you
know so I'm gonna make up some crazy
[ __ ] that would be so [ __ ] wild if
she made that up because I'm used to
weird [ __ ] I mean this is pretty dream
but she's like hit like around this
level you know so I'm like oh man this
better not be it because I was gonna see
them anyways the next day like literally
on Sunday I was supposed to have a
dinner with me my mom and my dad so I'm
driving
uh I get a phone call and I pick up and
then like hey this is detective whatever
from LA Sheriff's Department just want
to let you know and I was like oh [ __ ]
this is real
um so I was like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
crazy so I drove
um when I showed up at my mom's house I
see my dad's car there and that's like
[ __ ] chills again and I see her [ __ ]
I might see his [ __ ] I see my mom I
don't know what to say I just hug her
and um yeah it was just like a great
crazy news to find out that he
pretty much was like I'm uh I'm done
living like I don't have anything else
to live for or whatever
so that's pretty much like
what happened and ever since then it's
just you know there's like kind of like
you know when they don't teach you
anything about like taxes or buying a
home or anything like like that in high
school there's like the whole other side
of [ __ ] like when someone passes away
there's actually a lot of things you
have to go through so for example like
the body gets taken to the coroner's
office and it's up to you to like go to
the mortuary arrange with the mortuary
and they give you these case numbers and
then they get the body over there and
then you have to request death
certificates
um to like stop payment from
my dad subscribed to only fans or some
[ __ ] I have to like damn unsubscribe
like you don't get charged for that yeah
do you think the only fans model is like
I don't know what I did he canceled
do you think the only thing as well is
like oh man I killed another one [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] like that so I'm still going
through all of that stuff
um he's gonna get buried literally in
about like a week or so which is cool so
I feel like that is like in any
spiritual or religious play his body's
at rest and then I just have to get like
all his other paperwork and like close
accounts close credit cards you know so
how does that stuff work if
he just abruptly did it without a will
or anything and it's just like you just
have to be like I'm his son and this is
so good for him or good for me actually
you know my dad's kind of like a [ __ ]
Doomsday prepper but not really so like
just to catch you guys up my dad
[ __ ] like five years ago he would he
showed me that he has like eight pairs
of Kirkland shoes so he's a very like
he's like it's gonna last till my death
laughs you told me that I remember the
Fairy like
um what's the word brain yeah yeah
practical like anticipate the N type of
guy yeah very practical very very when I
was 20 something he already wrote a will
with all this stuff oh wow so and then
he gave it to me we had a meeting I went
to the notary like when I was 20. so I
remembered exactly what to do so how
many Kirkland shoes do you get who knows
I think he threw them all away he
probably [ __ ] got older they lost them
all
that's a very important thing to do yeah
so I have I have everything that's like
what's crazy is um on his will there was
[ __ ] 10 plots of land that he bought
at Rose Hills because like the place
that you bury people it's almost like
real estate they go up in value and
stuff so I call Rose Hills I'm like hey
there's like 10 plots of land um I guess
if you can name them all off to me I'll
find whichever one is the closest to
where my grandpa's buried and I'm
assuming that's probably what my dad
would want to be as close to Grandpa as
possible so they go through the computer
and they go actually nine of them have
been given away to some lady
oh my damn is my mom and my dad have
hoes on the side that I didn't know
about or that's a ball or move I'm like
what the [ __ ] so there's only one that
was available so it's just crazy like
after something ends
um there's just more questions than ever
because then I heard a name I've never
heard of before I'm like I don't know
who the [ __ ] that is and then while my
dad was living with me in Vegas he was
visiting some other person in Utah and I
look on his phone and that person's name
is under the name Little Flower it's his
nickname where yeah it was just like
more and more questions so it's like you
can go down this endless Rabbit Hole of
like investigating his life yeah but
there's like no point you know because
it's just like like even I texted my
dad's uh has six brothers and sisters I
texted his closest brother because
they're the the two youngest uh in the
family and they're closest in age and
they grew up together
and I'm like hey I have like some
horrible news to tell you and then the
first thing his brother told me was like
Hey if you have any guilt or anything
like that don't feel that
um we've had I've had many talks with
your dad in the last uh two months and
your dad's a very stubborn person and he
has only one perspective and he can't
change his mind so if you have any
energy to apply to this just apply it to
the next Generation make sure you raise
the Next Generation good and I was just
like that's really good advice yeah deep
is fun and that's your dad's older
brother or younger brother older brother
my dad's a younger you say don't you
[ __ ] talk about my dad like that
no you keep his [ __ ] Dave about
yourself again I don't care if he's your
brother
what'd you say about my pop yo [ __ ]
that's wild yeah it's just crazy it's
just it doesn't even feel real yeah we
were just doing the the Bart's dad and
mom story update and then now we have
this [ __ ] abrupt ass and ending to it
out of nowhere which is just Steve was
cracking Bart's dad jokes the whole time
although while your dad was dead the
whole time the whole time dude like I
can't [ __ ] believe you came in here
and still shot JK with us for like three
days and didn't mention anything and
just for everybody I don't want to ruin
the vibe no dude I believe you yeah for
sure you know that was your attention
you know you weren't trying to you know
like definitely doesn't you know
discount the fact that I think everyone
would understand don't go man just find
a replacement yeah seriously yeah and
then all he said is he didn't [ __ ]
want dancers to run the show which is a
great one you said that and I [ __ ]
died like I can't leave Steve hanging I
can't leave he's like I can't he wasn't
even here for that week I can't have
more dancers on the show than us that's
really good that's a [ __ ] love I love
that it's such a it's such a petty
[ __ ] line just for comedy's sake and
not for what's going on it says so much
especially in the heat of all that right
it's really good and then on top of that
you got to leave on Monday right because
we filmed Sunday oh now you gotta go
back to deal with the house stuff that's
a nightmare yeah the minute we Finn yeah
I left that leaves Sunday or Monday you
left Sunday night I think oh Sunday
night book a flight because I'm still in
the middle of handling the whole house
[ __ ] and they finally have the time I
can go sign so I go fly in there and
then uh so I'm just still dealing with
my Dad's passing two days ago I'm still
dealing with uh house signing and
Anthony calls me he goes is this a prank
yeah I was like what what the [ __ ]
going on but then I came back everything
was cool full context because
can't just leave me in the dust like
that we were all a part of it I just had
the cajones to actually call my lawn
care expert
yeah all of us are here with another one
of Bart's [ __ ] real estate people and
none of us [ __ ] know [ __ ] to do with
this guy talk about anything and we're
like dude we were nervous we were just
nervous like we're like maybe this is a
test yeah because we've never had full
rank like well yeah it was just it was
just me and Dick and Ryan basically we
thought it was we thought it was a test
yeah yeah we went to Jamba Juice and I
wasn't here is this a test we call him
is this a test like what are you talking
about yeah like I guess it's not a test
I mean it wasn't so much that he's a
realtor it's that we've never had a
guess that no one knows oh right yeah
there's no like Bridge yeah yeah yeah
and this is like the first weekend that
both Bart and Joe aren't here at one
point or like and also to be fair too we
just missed you guys we wanted to
FaceTime be like half of us hey dude
come on you were you missed part two bro
yeah I was not the mission you guys are
[ __ ] you guys what are you talking
about and I straight up just didn't
[ __ ] know because I wasn't here the
day where he pulled you guys aside and
told you yeah so oh you want to hear
that it was the group text I wasn't the
group text set me off because like we
have a host group text for like stupid
technical [ __ ] which is super boring so
I mostly skip it
um but then he deletes it but um but
Michael's like hey we got a family
emergency so we're gonna have to
um cancel like these patreon posts we're
gonna do and then Ryan immediately is
like oh well uh we're we already sent
out the promo like we're ready to go and
then uh Michael's like oh well Bart's
dad died and I was like what the [ __ ] I
was like what the [ __ ] oh yeah and then
I was just I mean what did Michael's
humor get so dark yeah I mean and I
immediately text Bart and I'm like Yo
dude I just found out like you know this
is [ __ ] crazy and then Bart says I
haven't seen him till today but he's
like he's like man yeah it's crazy
thanks man but he's like the story is so
[ __ ] crazy I can't wait to tell you
in person
and here I am
yeah so again it's been that long yeah
and then I come into I come into JK and
I'm [ __ ] you know lighting fireworks
in here oh he's got his [ __ ]
sunglasses on he's [ __ ] he's ready to
roast I'm [ __ ] going ham on me it's
back because yeah me and Joe were
[ __ ] barbing about some [ __ ] and
then yeah I I luck I let one rip real
quick and then I was like wait and then
during the break they're like Bart's dad
killed himself okay first of all before
before that even gets he he lets one rip
and he just he just makes some joke
about about your dad but no I made a
joke about Joe's parents and then I was
like lucky Bart's not here because then
I would have gone you know like that was
that was I didn't even say out of
contest in context of double down it
just made it like a very like uh hot off
the press yeah through a joke about that
particular thing it was a curveball but
but all of us who were more in the know
of even how it went down they're all
doubled over it was like a 911 joke on 9
12. yeah yeah
but then I'm crying dude I'm crying
because I'm laughing so hard
as well and then but he didn't know
that's why and I didn't know I'm
thinking you know I'm thinking because
Bart's like this story is so [ __ ]
crazy I'm thinking the guy went to Red
Lobster and choked on shrimp or
something I have no [ __ ] he didn't
know how he went he didn't know that I
didn't know like because I can't wait to
tell you the story's crazy and I know
Bart too like Bart kind of
um like is the first person who would
make the jokes yeah probably lighten
them up on his end so I was just like
once I found out about that and the the
way that your mom found him I was like
this is [ __ ] real [ __ ] like I had no
idea so we backed it up we were like hey
maybe we should cut that out
Steve was like hey whose idea was that
that was my idea it's like a day later
it was like Hey I was like I was
thinking about it I slept on it and I
think we should cut it out well because
to me I'm like man like because like you
know even just never having met your dad
but always hearing all these stories
about him for so long I I can't imagine
what like the audience who like feels
like they know your dad too they're
green too so it's like you know you have
to think about that too yeah because
they've seen them in Vlogs for like so
many years yeah yeah yeah and the most
recent uh update video that everybody's
gotten a chance to hear about this like
ongoing thing as well this whole Saga
was at
um you know you he basically uh moved in
with your mom then got kicked out again
so that was like all the information
that was let out you know what I mean
and it wasn't until fans started
commenting on our videos hearing about
the full story on your podcast part and
Geo yeah that I was like okay now the
fans do know yeah so you know just felt
a more appropriate time for us to come
together and uh one obviously for for a
very very loving and adoring fans and
supportive fans to just get like you
know our little talk about it because it
would also be weird to like fully give
every detail about the Saga and then
just drop off and never discuss it as if
we weren't close friends I feel like
like are you are you okay I don't know I
think I am I feel like I am okay
um I mean I was there when Jill's dad
passed away
and then so the way she dealt with it I
think was very similar to me where it's
like you're trying to you're more
focused on like is everyone else okay
and then like whatever
um procedures has done the correct way
so that it's like nice and buttoned up
and so Geo never really like like
mourned and who knows if it's like five
years later she just randomly breaks
down one day I don't know if that'll
happen to me
but so far it's it's been okay I guess
and I think for me like I'm a very
um what's the word like
like I let people like I feel like
everyone has their own decision to life
and what the choices they want to make
in their life so I'm a very like if
that's how you wanted to do it then
that's how you wanted to do it you know
like I'm like it's it's not on me to go
oh you have to stay alive or whatever or
you know just like yeah like if this is
how you wanna do anything
like if you want to I don't know sleep
at 10 or sleep at three or do whatever
like that's you and so I don't I feel
sad I'm like
because we were the whole like whole
Saga started with trying to create a
really cool life for my dad in Vegas
post pandemic where the family didn't
really see each other finally my dad and
uh taika can have a really cool
relationship so it just felt like we
were building momentum
in a certain direction for him to go you
know what
Side Track I'm gonna go talk to your mom
and then so I'm like wait what that was
wild I'm like what the [ __ ] like to even
get my dad's house so I think initially
the day of and maybe the week of I was
actually [ __ ] pissed at my death
because I was like [ __ ] I'm like
I'm already a busy person when you tell
me you wanted to move to Vegas like I I
checked out like 20 homes for you right
and then so we got you at home and you
told him not to come yeah I told you not
to come I was like wait I might be in
the honeymoon phase like I might move
back who knows so I was like chill out
and then he's like no I really have to
be with you guys I'm like all right fine
if you really have to do it then let me
check out 20 homes for you try to find
something that you like we got
everything set up for him to go you know
what I got another thought and he goes
to do to be with my mom and I already
told him I don't think that's a smart
move and I'm like you should approach it
as if like it's probably gonna fail but
if it if it um
succeeds that's a miracle and I told my
dad I was like we actually like the the
last day before we moved out of that
house had a heart to heart with my pops
and I told him I was like logically
moving in with mom is probably like the
stupidest thing in the world
um but I was like but emotionally I
support you because I was like when me
and Joe started JK 99 of people thought
we were the dumbest [ __ ] ever
so logically doesn't make any sense not
100 of them do it
Regrets by the way yeah remove the
needle yeah so I told the mother so if
you believe in this if you believe in
this and this is like what is your
life's purpose I was like don't let
don't let anyone stop you don't even let
me stop you so in that regard I support
you so he's like okay cool he's gonna go
he went to go do what he needed to do
and then the way that like and also as
an Asian Daddy's always harping on I
should have a second kid you know or
like they always paint all these dreams
of like I want to hang out with tiger
and do all this so when he ended his own
life I'm like bro like all the requests
you wanted where you're like I would
love to see Tyco get married one day or
I want to see a second kid I'm like how
the [ __ ] are you gonna see any of that
[ __ ] you know I'm like that's so like so
I was actually really pissed uh the
first week and then the second week I
think as you're trying to like when when
you have questions then you try to like
put yourself in their place and try to
like understand like what is going on
then I think the empathy comes in more
and I'm like damn my dad must have been
in a really really bad place for him to
um feel like he ran out of options and
he had to do it the way he did you know
yeah so I was like so now I'm in a um
what you call like uh more empathetic
and not so mad and just like well if
that's the way he felt like he had to
end his pain and that's I just I respect
it that's big that's honestly big yeah
yeah and it's less painful for you if
you could see it that way I think just
understanding his own story and how his
stubbornness got him there but it's also
he didn't see other options because he
didn't accept other options too how's
your mom doing so my mom's actually in
Vegas right now
um she's like super religious so she had
to do like a whole month of religious
practices to cleanse out him huh to
cleanse him out or something or yeah to
like cleanse him out or cleanse the
house or whatever and then so right
after my mom's I really need like every
Thursday through Sunday my mom's been
staying at a hotel
because she would just feel like like
the Luxor or some [ __ ] no no I mean that
back back in L.A oh okay yeah it should
be staying at hotel shut the Bally's
it's like at the park MGM yeah I'm just
so curious you know which one because
her house has such bad energy you know
yeah that's what I was thinking and
she's probably going to want to sell
that spot so after the I want to move
her out way sooner but she just has to
do her ceremony so like I support you
whatever so now she's
um in Vegas right now living with you
guys yeah she's been there for like a
week and uh Geo says that she seems like
way happier right now really yeah which
is because I think she's not reminded by
constant oh yeah there's no triggers
everywhere
finishes with new energy is she planning
on selling that place and getting
something oh yeah she's gonna she
doesn't know where to move to yet but
she's gonna sell it for sure I had a
just being in this room for so many
years as like when I found out about it
you know I'm just trying to like process
through it in my own brain and like
accept it or whatever I immediately had
a thought of I heard Joe's voice too of
him finding out about what happened to
your dad and then Joby and I man why
couldn't that happen to my dad
it's so true
it's so true probably it honestly
brought me so much light just thinking
about Joe saying that oh my God
flips the table
oh man
foreign